hey what's up everyone we're Eric and
Justin the minds behind battle-damaged
we got a lot of questions about the cart
we're here to answer those the one you
see on the show is probably like the
third or fourth version the first one
died the quickest and also took the
longest to build I modeled some custom
parts and then 3d printed them and it
all up really cool we have like the
names written on each section when we
did the first test everything shattered
on the bottom and just slid off I
underestimated how strong all the bottom
pieces needed to be to keep the cart on
the track I took a moment to not cry oh
well I was crying on the inside a lot
ran too you know big box hardware store
threw out everything all the bottom of
it this whole new much stronger all
steel these are just our elbow brackets
and now the motor is spring-loaded
so it should have tension but not break
the motor mounts like it did before
these motors each one is meant to power
like a giant RC plane with a military
drone yeah yes pretty much
the original goal was the car to spin
around 30 miles per hour which is
terrifying and when you watch it
spinning at 15 that's pretty scary
so to imagine it going twice as fast as
that what you see on the show is
probably those motors and that power
plant working at like 20% so they could
go a lot faster now it's not like we're
putting a GoPro yeah no $50,000 super
scientific specialty phantom camera that
person rented of course that we rented
we knew from the beginning we had to
armor this thing like a space skeleton
of the armor is heavy-duty l-brackets on
top of that is 3/8 inch Plexiglas when
you're filming at those high speeds it
can only capture four seconds and if
you're off by two seconds to view the
shot screw which happened
ah the scammers like so ridiculous it
doesn't even have buttons on it you have
to connect a laptop and that's the only
way to hit record finally you realize we
could wirelessly connect the camera to
laptop went from strapping a $700 five
pound laptop with its ass hanging out of
this car
to a $100 quarter pound little piece of
electronics that's why early
transmitting this has never been done
before so we're just a guess that it
would work well guys thanks for checking
this out thanks for being fans of
battle-damaged we really appreciate the
support you guys have given us and there
have been so many amazing suggestions we
want to battle test the things that you
want to see battle tested so leave in
the comments below here on the videos
tweet us and Facebook us and all those
things we'll see you next time thanks
for watching in a lab coat oh yeah
we'd better lab coats